oh yes about starting ready ready
popcorn but nachos she prepare with red
licorice all right it's time we made a
new movie good idea Scoob but first we
need a trailer oh can you do the
trailers high voice oh let me give it
Assad in the world destroyed by evil
discover the epic origin story the
greatest team of heroes
mystery
nailed it
[Music]
hi this mangy stray is coming with me
he's not a stray
okay then what's his name his name's hey
Scooby middle name doobie last name do
[Laughter]
would always be without you I feel -
that's I love it dark so you never take
it off maybe don't do that again
I'm Fred this is Velma hi
and that's Daphne hey I'm Shaggy and
this is scooby-doo nice to meet you
[Applause]
guy
No
whoa whoa whoa Shaggy and Scooby were
taken do you realize where we are no
look a real man the clean modernist
thing the cool blue color palette we're
in Mikey oh did you say I can't nope
I said solitaire just like you maybe
this can lead us to Scooby and Shaggy
trace amounts of moustache oil
twelve-year-old scotch
it's the bad guy my dad
[Music]